wenn jemand der sich als bürger
bezeichnet der sagt ich stehe auf den
grundgesetze auf den fundamenten des
grundgesetzes ich habe nichts mit
rechtsradikalismus zu tun ich habe nur
bestimmte ängste oder forderungen an die
politik dass meine kinder beispielsweise
wieder in die kita gehen wenn derjenige
auf eine demo geht wo auch
rechtsradikale neben ihm stehen
beispielsweise dann muss man diesen
bürger doch sagen pass auf das geht so
nicht
aber auch alternativen anbieten ja das
ist glasklar also ich kann jedem der ein
berechtigtes anliegen haben nur raten da
nicht hinzugehen stalker meidet diese
veranstaltung geht da nicht in
unterstützt mit ihrer anwesenheit nicht
die verrückten weder die
verschwörungstheoretiker nach links oder
rechtsextreme aber die politik da ist
dann unser job die muss natürlich denen
auch das gespräch anbieten also es gibt
ja auch noch andere veranstaltungsleiter
gesprächsform und oder man kann
schreiben oder man kann wählen oder man
kann per petition seinen unwillen
artikulieren
auch normale parteien die im
parteienspektrum sich befinden
du wohnst du mit deutschland bieten ja
auch termine oder gesprächsmöglichkeiten
an die bürger die ein echtes anliegen
haben sollen die anderen wege nutzen auf
jeden fall nicht zu diesem termin gehen
darum kann ich nur bitten
es hilft ihnen jährlich es hilft dem
anliegen nicht sie unterstützen damit ob
sie wollen oder nicht einfach weil sie
menge machen
das anliegen von verrückten und das ist
unser problem